hey how's it going bro new merch no late
game check it out link in the
description
all right cheap steak skates i can never
say that word
um i love these videos i don't know why
they're so
fascinating to me it's almost like
watching five minutes craft where
some someone do something that's oh
that's kind of nifty but it has no
practicality whatsoever that's what sort
of this feels like
uh meet them my mother's a cheapskate
and her mother wear a cheapskate
so i'm three generations of cheapskate
[Music]
it's a family tradition to bike down to
the dumpster trucks
my family's been dumpster diving for
generations hello how they have a word
for him
dumpster diving we're dumpster dashing
now you're just digging through the
trash my dude
my name's angel dirt and i am literally
the biggest cheapskate
in texas the biggest cheapskate
people see dumpster diving as like a
sport
i don't see it that way i just see it as
it's a life
it's a lifestyle it's a brain the thing
is these are only funny if people are
already well enough
right if there's actually poor people
struggling then it's not funny anymore
so i try to do it in the middle of the
day when people are working and stuff
like that
one of the main yo you found some
concrete there though aren't you gonna
get that
dumpster diving now are our medications
especially prenatal vitamins
what she's getting medication from the
trash
do not do not take meds from the trash
for the love of oh god don't try this at
home
by foraging through dumpsters behind
pharmacies and hospitals
25 year old angel durr has managed to
save more than 350 dollars on vitamins
and medications
flashbacks man i'm kind of just poking
around
to see if i can hear anything rattling
because generally that's a dead giveaway
of pills
i think oh my god don't stop it stop
i have to say stop
what who would throw away
meds unless they're expired right or
unless
uh are kind of
a lot of times they put expiration dates
on things way earlier than they need to
just to sell more products
oh no bingo yeah but how what are the
odds are you gonna find meds
that you need to take right oh what kind
of medicine she like she uh
it's folic acid which is good for
pregnancy so she
happened to find meds that are good for
pregnancy
that's not even safe i would that's way
too extreme for me thank you
thank you we recently bought a house
primarily because of see what i mean
they're always well off she owns she's a
house owner
but she's digging the trash people that
come to our house
we make a point to say hey that came out
of a dumpster
and then usually people are kind of
taken aback but at the same time they're
kind of like
oh wow yeah you say that to be nice
wow it's like oh was it a wow
or was it oh wow it's very different
just to be clear here
what the hell is that dumpster diving
i'm not in the minor leagues i'm in the
big leagues
we've been doing this in my family for
60 plus years
man it is kind of like christmas no
no it's not it's really i don't but to
paint the entire room
she'll need to collect 35 to 40 paint
cans yeah right
which he doesn't want to pay for no we
i mean at least you can get the paint
sample for free but then you have to buy
the paint
right right i assume they painted in
this color because no one wants to paint
their house in this awful color isn't
yellow like
what they used to torture people with oh
my god they're gonna try to get them for
free
me and orlando have been doing this a
long time so we've already hit up a lot
of places
hello being pregnant kind of gives me a
one-up on orlando
if she can get away with more than two
of the of the free samples i'll be
very impressed we have samples for 2.99
2.99 i'd like to work with you on that
how about free 99
did i miss something here it cost 2.99
and she
went to 3.99 what did you feel about
that
free um oh free ninety nine couple
gallons of paint maybe we can
work out something she ain't gonna do
that you're lying then
i wouldn't be buying any today today
maybe tomorrow maybe tomorrow
or the next day okay or never
[ __ ] you're lying to him you're a liar
you're a stinky liar
i don't like liars think it is kind of
unusual for
someone to haggle over a small sample of
paint
but she was very nice lady she was
decorating a
nursery so thought i would help her out
she's not nice
she's taking advantage of your niceness
oh i hate those
stop it i approached it like i
approached every situation
you're stealing or you're stolen you're
stealing i always think that you get
more flies with sugar than you do with
vinegar so
obviously it worked it makes me angry
man this life can typically cost new
parents upwards of twelve thousand
dollars
but for cheapskate mom to be angel durr
spending this kind of money is simply
out of the question you own the house
stop it
they got a stroller in here really the
most important thing right now is for us
to get a breast pump
but i'm not about to do not take the
breast pump out of the trash
do now and stop taking meds down i
refuse
i'm illegal illegal i'll make the i made
it illegal
i can't believe i'm googling this oh
she's right [ __ ] 200
i ain't paying for that [ __ ] 20 bucks 20
bucks it's 20 buckaroonies
sucks sucks up all right what's the
problem
yeah they can cost up to 200. that
doesn't mean they can't
cause ah breast pumper rooney
dollars on a breast pump if somebody
else could build it i could build it so
why not make it myself how are we gonna
build a
vacuum bruh what are you gonna do i want
to see this oh i want to see this please
please show us the brush pump he made
maybe he's [ __ ] a genius and he
nails it i wanna oh my god have you
thought about like
how you're gonna put it together and
everything yeah i was thinking about
um uh what do they call like a trap it's
called a truck in swedish
yeah one of the one of those yeah put it
on and
you know when you have to empty the fish
fish tank and you have to stop
and then the rust comes out you just get
one funnel that's what it's called
you get a funnel do like beer pong
[Music]
it's a blockage i gotta blow pretty
comfortable being a guinea pig for
orlando's breast pump because i trust
him and i know that he's not gonna do
anything to hurt me
if he orlando try to at least have the
dignity to try the breast pump out
yourself
first please me i'm gonna kill him
angel's taking
this a little bit further she really
doesn't have to
but i think she just has gotten to the
point where she's she doesn't spend
money on anything
well she bought a house she'd spend
money all night we're just hoping that
we'll find what we need to finish the
pump
how the guys here are pretty cool
because anything under 20 or 30 pounds
we can take for free
what about this plastic thing down here
[Laughter]
yeah oh i can called it
there's the funnel it was just
conveniently laying there i'm sure they
didn't place it there at all
oh that's a tiny funnel about this
little one
yeah that looks good you think you could
do something with that what about this
maybe when i saw those two i gave myself
a chuckle because
i have no idea what they're gonna end up
doing with that stuff but i wish them
the best of luck
basically a bicycle pump uh-huh
i don't what happened to the funnel it's
free milk
nothing's better than free free milk
he's referring to
breast milk as free milk
i feel so bad for that poor sweet paint
man brushing it's not coming back
yeah right okay furniture is okay but
yeah right and but meds and breasts from
that's horrible
she's saying don't try this at home
because she doesn't want people stealing
her stuff i don't think so
i think if anyone should use it it
should be him first
oh hell yeah i've tested out on him
before do you see that [ __ ] face
look what it hits oh damn
damn son damn son i think i keep this
one for myself we got quite the suction
on it
yeah free breast milk come on
oh you didn't even try
you didn't even [ __ ] try did you
like sure you can be creative on a
budget but
that ain't that ain't it
[Laughter]
angel puts the finishing touches on the
painting having used
finishing touches on me this is my
orlando 3000.
[Music]
i'll probably be sleeping on the couch
angel in orlando they will always go to
incredible extremes
to save a dollar i don't see angel ever
stopping she's gonna be
just like this and you know at 25 she'll
be like this at 75.
it doesn't really matter how much money
i make i'm always gonna i guess it's a
kid's room you know what secret and
something that
doesn't really matter to me about what i
spend it on i feel like we're still
going to dumpster dive
that's nice we should get a tattooed on
our back though
for life my mother dumpster dives it's
in my dna
she dumps her dives for medication nah
that's way too extreme for me
yeah when she was after driving for
medication she said don't try this at
home not shoddy don't try this at all
it's so weird how it's like it's a sport
right they're so into it
i i don't think they have to do it they
just seem to like doing it
which i guess fair enough but my god
you're pregnant and you're dumpster
diving medicine i don't know it doesn't
seem that good of a deal to me
the nursery would look better orange
yeah kind of to be honest
we should get a tattooed do you or do
you have expired ink or maybe
use needles
oh god see what i mean these are just so
fascinating to me
i don't get it i'm intrigued and i but i
would never ever do it myself
anyway that's it for this video new
merch check it out thanks for watching
guys
brofist